[Musique]
panel américain ce soir avec un zèbre
qui était Washington et Raphaël Jacob à
Montréal bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
Patrice grosse semaine pour les
républicains mais grosse semaine pour
les démocrates aussi on va parler de la
visite de Joe Biden ici on parlait de
Fox new je disais commençons avec les
républicains discours de Trump la fin de
semaine dernière à Z de Santis qui lui
déroule son programme est-ce que les
choses se précisent dans la lutte de ces
deux-là vont se faire mais en fait on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est l'élève
qui dépasse un peu le maître là en fait
officiellement rente de sentis fait la
campagne pour son livre le courage
d'être libre donc et là il était en Iowa
aujourd'hui pour parler justement de son
livre et on sent vraiment qu'il commence
à avoir de la popularité Trump quand il
a été à la messe des conservateurs leipa
qui disait écoutez je suis votre
guerrier je suis là pour vous je suis là
pour vous représenter donc il reste
quand même extrêmement populaire
d'ailleurs il y a eu un sondage après le
Sipa qu'en disant qu'il était encore
100% des républicains votaient pour lui
mais loin de Saint this demeure
populaire il a des valeurs très à droite
vous savez qu'il est anti avortement à
partir de 6 semaines maintenant quand
c'est le battement du cœur du fœtus
enfin c'est ce qu'il dit donc il
commence à être populaire en AOA il fait
toujours celle-combe et on veut savoir
plus sur ce gouverneur de la Floride
parce que ça a très bien fonctionné pour
lui en Floride et puis évidemment comme
il n'est pas encore candidat officiel
Trump pour le moment on a l'impression
qu'il garde un peu ses munitions pour
plus tard bon Raphaël comment vous voyez
là cette semaine le combat de la droite
américaine premièrement on parle très
souvent moi premier des armes que
Monsieur Trump pourrait presque surement
pourra utiliser contre un dacentes il y
en aura et prise de Mac monsieur Dos
Santos se lance dans la course dans les
prochaines semaines ou les prochains
mois on va tous les toutes les découvrir
ensemble je pense qu'on oublie peut-être
que Monsieur De Santis aussi a et aura
des armes contre Donald Trump et pour
avoir regardé intégralement son
allocution d'aujourd'hui en Iwa à Z
mentionné facettes qu'il était là
officiellement pour faire la promotion
de son livre il s'est empressé
d'ailleurs de mentionner le fait qu'il
était numéro un sur la liste des
meilleurs vendeurs de la semaine je
dirais que s'il était à côté de Trump
mais si il était peut-être une
différence près dans lequel monsieur de
santé c'est peut-être lui qui a écrit
son propre livre contrairement au livre
de Monsieur Trump une fois que ça s'est
dit s'il était en iwat je dirais que
c'est pas tant pour vendre davantage de
copie c'était pour se vendre lui et il a
fait écouter point par point les
arguments de vente pour une éventuelle
campagne présidentielle incluant son
opposition et il a mentionné par son nom
à au moins trois reprises un certain
Docteur inténifacci doit-on rappeler
pour la petite histoire Patrice quand
même s'il y avait eu évidemment beaucoup
de tension entre monsieur
fartchatchi et de leur champ il reste
que le docteur fatchi a travaillé au
sein de l'administration Trump ça vous
pouvez être sûr et certain que si et
quand on a une course Trump de sentis
monsieur De Santis va se faire un
plaisir de
et il fait de santé cette lutte contre
ce qu'il appelle les walk puis à l'école
puis donc à Z dans les écoles il se sert
de son état il dit regardez ce que je
fais ici je veux le faire à l'échelle
des États-Unis revenir à des valeurs
traditionnelles plus de droites là
exactement en fait il dit que dans les
écoles c'est plus l'éducation là on
apprend plus à lire ou à compter c'est
de l'endoctrinement donc qui dit qu'on
apprend l'homosexualité ou sur les
questions de genre encore sur les
questions de race donc lui il dit que
l'école s'est fait juste pour apprendre
et il est quand même extrêmement
populaire là-dessus et d'ailleurs vous
savez il a remporté sa lutte contre
Disney aussi là-dessus là maintenant il
a dit écoutez Disney n'aura plus cette
espèce de statut spécial en Floride ça
va être la Floride qui va décider de de
tout ce qui est de tout le secteur
public de Disney donc run de sentis
surtout son combat contre la culture wok
comme il dit il est quand même assez
populaire là dessus
disent que bon écoutez ça marche en
Floride il dit que c'est un état libre
il dit que durant la pandémie rien n'a
été fermée nous étions pas des états
comme on n'a pas du tout écouté le
docteur facher là dessus les populaires
pour pour Disney aussi donc donc là
dessus c'est il reste très populaire en
Floride mais ce qui va être populaire au
niveau national c'est ça la grande
question un point très très rapide parce
qu'il est important lorsqu'on se parle
de sa popularité Azem ancienne sa
popularité en Floride monsieur de Santos
revient constamment à la charge avec sa
marge de victoire en 2022 le fait qu'il
est passé d'une marge de victoire
initiale en 2018 lorsqu'il a été élu la
première fois comme gouverneur de peu
près 30000 voix et que ça ça s'est
creusé en un écart en 2022 4 ans plus
tard en novembre dernier de plus d'un
virgule 5 millions de voix sauf pour
être sûr et certain on se parle
d'attaque qu'on donne dans le temple le
contraste va être assez flagrant pour
Monsieur de santé de dire j'ai gagné
vous avez perdu rapidement les sondages
du côté républicain le donne comment par
rapport à Trump
il y a plusieurs sondages en fait le
dernier sondage qui a été fait justement
en Iowa vous savez dans notre champ
était à 60 plus de 60% en ioa là il est
baissé quand même à 47% alors qu'en 2021
il était à 60% donc la popularité de
Trump commence à baisser puis vous savez
il y a toutes ces enquêtes judiciaires
contre talent aujourd'hui on a EUA
rendez-vous
il y a aucun drame il y a pas d'intrigue
dans ma campagne je suis un homme clair
libre j'ai pas de passer voilà
donc très bien Raphaël Joe Biden hier
dépôt avant-hier des pots du budget qui
est un peu sa carte de visite pour la
prochaine campagne faire payer les
riches les les milliardaires les
millionnaires aussi les impôts et donc
des riches des taxe minimale pour les
milliardaires de vingtaine pour cent
bien sûr que ça passera pas mais il
envoie un message de ce qu'il veut quoi
plaider en campagne oui en fait vous
parler de carte de visite je c'est la
carte de visite d'à peu près tous les
candidats présidentielles du côté
démocrate on peut remonter à la course
strummond de Win 1948 jusqu'à celle
d'Obama ramené en 2002 c'est une carte
que Monsieur Biden lui-même a joué comme
colistine Monsieur Obama à la fin en
2008 et 2012 on va taxer davantage les
grandes entreprises les particuliers les
mieux entier on va réinvestir tout ça
dans la classe moyenne on va défendre
les programmes sociaux en même temps
vous l'envoyer mentionné vous-même il y
a un instant Patrice déposez une
proposition budgétaire aux Etats-Unis
pour un président ce n'est pas du tout
la même chose que dépose un budget pour
un ministre des Finances dans un
parlement majoritaire dans notre système
du côté nord de la frontière donc il y a
quand même ça qui doit être compris
d'emblée c'est du positionnement
prélectoral pour un président qui même
s'il ne l'a pas encore fait
officiellement semble clairement
déterminer à briguer un deuxième mandat
en même temps je vous dirais que pour
Monsieur Biden d'un point de vue à la
fois électoral économique ce qui va être
le plus important je dirais à ce
stade-ci et probablement dans un an là
sur cette voie si ce n'est pas tant les
propositions budgétaires fiscales qu'il
a à faire c'est pas mal l'état
d'économie à quel point est-ce que
l'inflation est juguler ou non à quel
point est-ce que la situation de
l'emploi continue à être relativement
la question la plus fondamentale elle
est vraiment là parce que AZ l'économie
de l'aide actuellement oui l'inflation
peut faire mal mais la création d'emploi
est presque historique aux États-Unis
absolument et Biden la mentionné à
plusieurs reprises je pense qu'en
janvier c'était historique là les
nouveaux emplois qui ont été créés par
l'administration Biden mais ce qui est
intéressant dans son discours d'hier
c'est qu'en fait il parle à la classe
moyenne il parle aux personnes qui ont
des revenus moindres et il l'a dit il a
dit I see you je vous vois tous ceux qui
sont invisibles et son budget devait
faire plaisir à quelqu'un comme Bonnie
Sanders vous savez on va imposer plus
les riches on va s'occuper également des
parents on va les gens qui gagnent plus
de 400 000 dollars par année vont être
imposés davantage donc il dit que ça n'a
aucun sens il avait souligné durant son
discours sur l'état de l'Union que un
professeur ou encore un pompier soit
imposé de la même façon auxquelles
milliardaire camillénaire évidemment
pour la gauche mais aussi pour les gens
qui ont justement des revenus
voilà la classe moyenne c'est quelque
chose qui résonne énormément mais la
grande question évidemment les
républicains me coltillent déjà dit là
il y a trop de dépenses et puis là ils
sont en train de négocier avec les
démocrates le plat de foiement de la
dette vous savez que si on n'arrive pas
à une décision avant le mois de juin à
la fin juin début juillet
le pays peut être en défaut de paiement
donc qui va y avoir une négociation donc
ce budget en fait c'est un peu une
feuille de route là pour négocier avec
les républicains très bien est-ce que on
est certain j'aurais dû vous poser la
question avant qu'il se représente
Raphaël pour vous sur une évidence aussi
Raphaël ça me semble extrêmement
probable en même temps dans ces
questions de décider au nom de se
présenter pour une campagne électorale
une campagne de réélection
ultimement c'est la décision d'un
individu et cet individu-là a toujours
pas rendu cette décision publiquement
pour l'instant donc la réponse prudente
vous est ce n'est pas certain mais
écoutez il fait absolument tout ce qu'un
pas tout en mode prélecteur absolument
Ferré écoutez sa propre épouse le répète
ça à peu près tous les toits il est
essentiellement dans la course donc
est-ce que c'est possible que la
dernière seconde et le recul oui mais ça
se casse ce statut je crois surprenant
d'une surprise absolument et sa femme en
a parlé comme me dire Raphaël plusieurs
entrées sont quand même sauf qu'en fait
il faut réaliser que l'échéancier
continue d'être constamment repoussé au
début de l'année on s'attendait à une
décision qui serait rendue publique
janvier ferry on est rendu en mars là on
évoque le printemps l'été voir peut-être
même l'automne mais que quand même ça
qui mérite d'être mis comme peut-être
petit bémol ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
sera Ottawa les 23 et 24 mars prochain
en personne la première visite avait été
reportée compte tenu de la covid le
dernier qui est venu en vrai c'est Obama
ma foi oui c'est ça
Obama monsieur Biden
monsieur Trump était venu tu es venu à
Charlevoix doit-on rappeler dans un
domaine
ok alors vous attendez à quoi
Raphaël je commence avec vous cette
visite là on a beaucoup parlé de la
poussée migratoire mais vraiment vous
attendez à quoi premièrement sur la
forme je m'attends quelque chose de
justement plus cordial que la dernière
fois qu'on est la visite d'un président
américain je le disais en 2000 blagues
mais en mettant la barre est assez basse
on a beaucoup parlé dans les médias
surtout du côté canadien du fait que
Monsieur Biden avait rompu avec la
tradition là Monsieur Trump monsieur
bouche paire monsieur Clinton Monsieur
Obama monsieur bouche fais également
c'était tous rendu rapidement après le
début de leur mandat au Canada pour une
première visite formelle ça va avoir
pris un peu plus de deux ans pour
Monsieur Biden mais en même temps
contenu du contraste extrêmement
frappant et négatif de son prédécesseur
immédiat lors de sa première et son
unique visite au Canada monsieur Trump à
Charlevoix en 2018 là-bas encore une
fois d'un point de vue diplomatique elle
est basse donc c'est possible
sur le fond ce à quoi s'attendre je
dirais du côté américain je crois qu'on
va vouloir faire ce qu'on fait avec à
peu près tous les leaders occidentaux
depuis maintenant à peu près un an c'est
à dire projeter une image d'unité dans
ce qui est de du conflit de face à la
Russie on a vu le président Biden je
vois cette carte là avec Monsieur chaos
le chancelier allemand il y a quelques
jours je m'attendrai quelque chose de
semblable avec Monsieur Trudeau du côté
canadien vous avez évoqué il y a un
instant vous-même Patrice la migration
évidemment qu'on va vouloir en parler
mais c'est écouté c'est quelque chose
qu'on a toujours gardé en tête même si
c'est peut-être difficile avec notre
lorgnette au Québec au Canada écoutez on
a beau avoir l'impression qu'on vit une
crise en Guinée migratoire ici c'est
absolument rien comparativement à ce qui
se passe du côté sud de la frontière
américaine avec le Mexique donc pour
interpeller le président américain faire
en sorte que non seulement son
administration comment s'adresser
davantage le problème mais que les
autres alliés de gouvernement aux
États-Unis aussi en fond de même c'est
pas nécessaire
attentes Azeb peut-être du côté canadien
on va s'efforcer au cours des prochains
jours de baisser les attentes ne vous
attendez pas qu'il y a un papier signé
par Roxane c'est peut-être pas ça qui
s'en vient faire ici monsieur baiden
qui est pas d'entendre de tiers là eux
ils aimeraient bien que les migrants qui
sont aux États-Unis postulent pour aller
au Canada parce que comme le dire
Raphaël en 2022 il y a eu plus de 2,7
millions d'interceptions à la frontière
du Mexique donc c'est énorme par rapport
aux 40 000 au Canada c'est sûr que ça
fait pas vraiment le poids mais durant
leur rencontre ils vont également parler
du protectionnisme américain depuis le
début la jobaddin dit qu'il faut
fabriquer aux États-Unis que ce soit au
niveau des puces électroniques et
certainement qui va avoir des questions
là-dessus pour le Canada est-ce que
c'est à l'avantage du Canada tout se
protectionnisme américain il sera aussi
question d'Haïti les États-Unis
aimeraient que le Canada et peut-être
une force
multinationale en Haïti juste un truc
doit déjà dit qu'il veut avoir Laval du
peuple haïtien donc il va y avoir des
discussions aussi sur iti puis aussi sur
le Norat de là on l'a vu avec les
ballons espions les deux pays ont réussi
quand même à bien collaborer donc il va
être question également de renforcer
évidemment cette alliance là
en Amérique du Nord
va devoir faire attention de pas
embarrasser monsieur Trudeau d'un point
de vue de politique interne
une ressortissante chinoise qu'on a vu
ce qui est ce qui est arrivé ensuite on
parlera de stormy Daniel une autre fois
il y aura pas d'accusation demain matin
quand monsieur Trump puis Fox News une
autre fois également mais c'est vraiment
intéressant ce qui se passe là-bas à
vous deux merci beaucoup bonne fin de
semaine pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]